espace pour la vie apporte un bout de
l'univers au coin de notre rue il nous
invite à redécouvrir la nature qui nous
entoure sous un nouveau jour
cette nappe ça s'appelle le plan cinq
majeur où le grand pantin
alors vous la reconnaissez certainement
cette nantes le ici qui pousse à peu
près partout sa part repoussé par
exemple dans le béton et cette note là
des propriétés médicinales
donc ça c'est quelque chose qu'on sait
pas où ils sont près de la feuille et
qu'on l'a par exemple ont l'air on a
retiré le joug le suc
on mettra sur les aventures des piqûres
d'un moustique ça pourrait soulager les
végétaux animaux insectes minéraux
phénomènes atmosphériques étoiles la
ville et tommies est vivante et à ciel
ouvert pour qui sait où regarder
on arrive le matin les animateurs
regarde l'environnement dans lequel ils
sont c'est eux qui décident qu'est-ce
qu'on qu'est ce qu'on va faire ressortir
de cet environnement de ses programmes
d'animation et de sciences citoyennes
sont dans l'adn des espaces pour la vie
nous puissions c'est de reconnecter lui
même assure donc comment mieux connecter
la nature que la nature qui est autour
de toi qui dit mieux connaître dit aussi
aimé davantage
est ce qu'on entend des oiseaux est ce
qu'on attend des insectes est ce qu'on
s'est dit sensibilisation donc faire
faire partie de la nature se reconnecter
à la nature c'est d'habiter ensemble sur
cet espace là et là bas on va peut-être
la préserver et préserver cette
biodiversité là il donnait plus de place
à l'intérieur des villes une initiative
qui a semblé plaire aux visiteurs petits
et grands pas et fermé j'ai beaucoup
aimé ça parce que bon on n'a pas
toujours le temps de se rendre dans
l'est dans les équipements fermé et
centre où nous ça c'est pas nos enfants
ses 9e et 10e en effet servi pour les
sortir et laisse pour sortir de la crise
et qu'on les garde
aujourd'hui avec ça tombe bien pour nous
durant 68 jours jusqu'au mois de
septembre et les compétences pour la vie
vont circuler comme ça dans les parcs à
travers la ville mais également autour
de montréal laval longueuil prix visitez
le site d espace pour la vie pour avoir
les détails sur leur prochaine sortie
trois jours à l'avancé ici mais bien les
cendres chartier radio canada montréal